[music]
>>Giving everybody a voice from anywhere in
the planet. And I don't even think it's that
hard to do.
>>We need to reach out as caring citizens
and to help get these poverty victim's lives
back on track.
>>Somehow remodeling the economic system to
take into account [pause] the environment.
>>High schools should have scholarships for
seniors leaving the school.
>>A vehicle that runs on something other than
gasoline, that can easily be sold around the
world for everyone to access.
>>Recycling saves energy. Pass it on. Spread
the word. Don't trash. Recycle, pass it on.
>>Recycle, pass it on.
>>Too much of our resources go into livestock
production. Every year roughly 60 million
people starve to death. If America were to
reduce it's meat intake by just 10 percent
those 60 million people could be adequately
fed.
>>First, everybody of us and one euro or one
dollar or whatever you're paying in your contribute
for this government.
Second, it must be forbidden by law for elected
politicians to work for any corporations or
to have any other jobs beside.
If the government is paid directly by us it
might start to work directly for us. Know
what I'm saying.
>>Make solar panels by the millions, in India,
Europe, America, Japan.
[violin music]
>>My solution to Davos question is that governments
around the world take more action to rid people
of their complaints and mind sets, and encourage
citizens to be more eco friendly. Like giving
away things like free exhaust pipe filters
and coupons on energy saving bulbs. In short,
you need to start teaching people to stop
relying on the person next door to save the
world.
>>To accept and cherish in a positive, constructive
matter, the works of others. And to respect
yourself by only doing constructive things.
>>We can save thousands, if not millions,
of lives by simply providing mosquito nets
to malaria ridden areas around the world.
>>We should be putting money into researching
the genetic engineering of plants so that
we can get more food out of every acre of
farm land.
>>Make a website on which can be put lectures,
or debates, discussions about all sorts of
important subjects like politics, economics,
religion, all that kind of stuff.
>>If Central America was to unite in a manner
of cooperation much like the European union,
I believe they could have a much better economic
growth and they could more evenly distribute
funds to where it's most desperately needed.
>>The answer is simple, it's one word, perspective.
Global perspective.
>>At no other time in history have the countries
of this world been more empowered to promote
education.
>>Solutions must be made through collaboration
and knowledge and that is how we should change
the world.
>>Smile.
>>Have an open mind about everything and admit
that you could be wrong.
[music]